hi guys Tyler and I were sent out this
past week to visit Axl for the
make-a-wish Foundation it was a
last-minute trip but we were happy to go
and when we got there we guessing me Axl
his whole family the hospital staff
everyone in the support group and it was
just a really cool time because there
was food video games and we just spent
all day pretty much playing rocket
leaving Skylanders and he kicked our
butts at rocket League real bad either
that or we're just playing bad at it but
it was a lot of fun and then Axl towards
the end of the day had something that
you wanted to tell you guys and I
promised him that I put it in a video so
here's that message so we're here with
Axl's an axle wanted to say something to
you guys you have a prepared statement
of speech of some sort no I just think
sarah was supporting markiplier come on
I can't I can't describe to him and I
don't have my own YouTube Google down
what if I did I would I would comment on
everything of this video and subscribe
and like on videos so thank you so much
for for helping mark and know I can
really thank you so much it was really
interesting to hear that and it's not
what I expected him to say because I've
never heard it from that perspective
before where someone is an avid fan yet
they weren't able to support what I do
and I was honored oh I was kind of
humbled because I get so much support
and it was a reminder that I'm literally
not here or I wouldn't be here if it
weren't for you guys I wouldn't be where
I am today and I wouldn't be able to do
what I want to do and I wouldn't be able
to do these charity efforts
wouldn't be able to go out and visit
people for their wishes if it weren't
for you guys I just want to thank you
everyone for being there for me and
supporting what I do in supporting what
we do here just making it something
really really special so tonight I just
wanted to be short and sweet this video
is mostly about Axel's message so I'll
leave it at that
just thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye